yeah i haven't really been up too much
either i've kind of just been
working
i went to
uh behind barbecue a bunch that was fun
was chill nice it was nice it was
raining though how's the weather been
here i was like i guess i was good
literally you answered my question as i
was processing what i was going to say
so this place i stayed at like a place
outside where you could still barbecue
even if it was raining because it was
like covered right that was fun and it
was yeah it was fun i liked it it's a
good time for barbie coming right now
yeah yeah
so that was chill got to do that that
was fun i just smelled of smoke three
days it was fun and then we had like a
bonfire and then it was very fun because
you just keep adding yeah we just chop
our own wood as well that was fun oh
there's camping vibes yeah yeah yeah
it's very nice because it would happen
did you have like an axe and everything
it was a hammer and there was like a
thing where you put the log on and it
was like like a metal thing like this oh
nice smack it into it oh cool i could
just hear like the i don't know like the
the dwarf music from lord of the rings
in my head just like well i was like
smacking away just like bring me another
log
as you were chopping in your beard just
exist
[Applause]
you should put on like
one of those like lumberjacks yeah
i was like yeah this is what it's all
about you're bringing my logs over like
this i'm like all in the fire we go
the the red and black checkered shirt
you know
this is so fun i don't know why chopping
wood was so fun your hair just turns red
and bought a bunch of
food and barbecued it and we i bought
way too much food because it was really
hard to eat at all i mean it is costco i
know i know so much food but it was so
[ __ ] good it's so delicious
barbecuing yeah i love bbq how long were
you there for oh like three days so
pretty chill pretty chill it's nice to
relax get away yeah and just uh chill
for a bit before i guess i'm gonna go
away again but it's because like this
next
two three weeks just all work so
and then going to the uk yeah a little
bit of work
yeah wedding and stuff i'm trying to
like
pack as much as i can before i fly back
because it's definitely like i was like
yeah i'm go i can work at home i have
like i have like a dedicated office
where i can work and stuff if i need to
but it's just something about being out
of japan my body's just like you are in
holiday mode now yeah you do why do you
need to work people are out people want
to see like i'm telling myself i'll be
like i'll have a bit of time in the uk
to like do some stuff yeah i could
probably just like sneak in i know
though the moment i get there i was just
like yeah so pop pop i wanna i wanna
live stream but i just feel like i'm
gonna be stream sniped into oblivion in
london
if i'm drinking at a pub yeah yeah
that'd be fun though trash taste is
definitely like
it's definitely changed things for me in
the uk in terms of yeah i was about to
ask like how much will you like
recognize in the uk uh
i compared to before
a lot
like the [ __ ] like at this wedding i
went to the bartender was a fan of trash
taste right
no way
[Laughter]
to like giving him like a free drink
because because she was like you
recognize him but you don't recognize me
how dare you how dare you it's
she's literally been on the show one
time and she's like i'm the one who's on
track you know who i am i am getting
married to him actually
she was also very intoxicated at this
time as we all were but um
no but uh yeah like because brighton has
become like i guess youtuber city they
like it's so weird like i can't like
sometimes i'll just be sitting at my
local pub um which i won't say but it is
my local pub so it is within the
vicinity which in which i live um and
it's very like nervous whenever
nerve-wracking whenever like i get
recognized there because
one it's weird to go to like the pub
that you grew up in and that you always
went to and you know you uh you grew up
there um and now you go there and
sometimes the odd person just recognizes
you from trash taste and it's always
trash taste it's all like yeah it's all
trash taste so
um sometimes like people recognize me
even though i go like i got the mask on
when i'm like walking in brighton um
it's it's super super surreal because
obviously it's the place i grew up in
and now it's like it's become this
really hip
happening influence the city you know um
basically the la of uk when it comes to
youtube yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely definitely so there's like
there's actually like i think i got
recognized more in brighton per se than
i did in london because london's like a
brit more spread out it's a bit more
like it's more dispersed you know i do
get recognized the odd place in london
but definitely like in brighton it's
it's way more concentrated like whenever
i go to the city center it's you know
and there's normally like one or two
people that recognizes me from trash
taste yeah yeah
probably be the same for you guys as
well
maybe yeah i blend in really well though
[Laughter]
yeah it's going to be interesting
because like we haven't really like you
know since trash day started we haven't
really like had that yet right yeah it's
like you know the borders have been
closed here so like not as many
foreigners coming to japan i mean a
little more recently i'd say i mean i've
been like i i don't know if you've
noticed but like the past like month or
so i'd be like oh yeah i got recognized
white people
twice in one day the other day oh really
yeah yeah i've noticed there's like a
lot more people now shinjuku oh okay
well that makes sense yeah yeah yeah so
that was like i was like whoa that's
weird it's happening a lot more yeah
because people are coming in now like
they've uh made it a lot easier to uh
get in the country uh at least my
experience was uh this time i spent an
hour and an hour and a half in the
airport as opposed to four hours so it's
nice which is nice
they've like the the first thing i
noticed is that they removed the [ __ ]
cattle tag that they that they like give
everyone so i didn't feel like livestock
which was a nice positive yeah like i
can't imagine if you like you're waiting
for years to come in you know your work
visa finally the [ __ ] country opens
and the first thing they do is like tag
you like [ __ ] you like [ __ ] brandy
you know
so you know
thank god they've removed that system
yeah everything's just a lot more
streamlined now um and i mean it's like
it's a lot easier traveling outside of
the country as well i mean england i
didn't even need to get tested or
give like a vaccine certificate or
anything it's just it's just back to
normal right
god bless the queen
[Laughter]
it's kind of crazy yeah oh yeah
hopefully it lasts because like the one
thing i'm really [ __ ] worried about
is you know while we're overseas like
say god's wedding and then they'll just
like
discover the new strain guys
let's go yeah even if they do people
like no yeah
i don't think so
well the one thing that i am i don't
know if i'm looking forward to or
dreading is the next convention we guys
we we go to yeah we can't announce what
it is yet yeah yeah we are going to
conventions we're going to go going to
several conventions but
like i remember what it was like before
trash taste i can't imagine what going
to a convention is going to be like
conflict
was always a thing you know and now it's
like confluent steroids is a thing now
yeah one one thing we've definitely like
we've definitely had to
plan around
that i've never we've never needed to do
before in conventions is uh uh like
planning what we're doing and the events
we're going to is that technically we
are now a fire hazard you know yeah
we are now a fire hazard uh so
that's something that i never had to
think about before yeah so people asking
like do you want security and i'm like i
feel so weird yeah yeah
i do i already want a guy just following
me around but then i guess i don't want
to get hurt but i mean it feels weird
yeah it does it definitely feels weird
because it's definitely a different kind
of planning than any like than any of
the conventions i've been to before um
because like i've always seen like you
know there's been like a couple of big
guests at like conventions i've been to
right that have security guards and
security and i was just like
look at
[Applause]
and i don't know how to feel about that
because like i don't want to be like
guys i i don't need all this extra [ __ ]
come on guys come on guys i'm just i'm
just a guy i'm just a guy but at the
same time like i'm like especially being
back this time being like i can't even
walk down my local streets how's it
going to be where all of the weebs and
all of the people without interested in
your content um and your you know and
your content field are going to be
concentrated in one place and i'm just
like that's uh pretty scary no i think
about it i've never been cool though i
mean
it's gonna be really cool i haven't seen
it in a while i'm excited to see what it
is yeah yeah the last fan meetup i had i
can't remember it's quite there's a
decent amount of people who showed up to
it so yeah i don't even know if i can
even do a fan meetup this time yeah yeah
i was i was talking to allen and he was
just like yeah remember when you used to
do like unofficial fan meetups yeah i
don't think that's happening this time
and i'm just like yeah because it is it
is a fire hazard or like that has to be
taken into account when we do any kind
of meetups now like how are we gonna
arrange people who come to see us and
are we blocking anything that could
potentially be a health and safety
hazard it sucks though because i missed
this off the convention people yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because i i used to do like those kinds
of like casual fan meetups every now and
then with aki and like i missed that
[ __ ]
it's like it's because it's so chill
yeah cause it's like you know you just
like you just tweeted out being like hey
we're going to be here for a couple of
hours if you want to hang out just go
hang out and it's usually like you know
like
50 people max and that's like a sizeable
amount of to be like yeah okay you know
what this is yeah this is going to be
you can talk to people yeah
you can talk to everyone you can have a
conversation with everyone
where people have come from and yeah
yeah i've met like so many cool people
through that and now it's just sucks
that like yeah it's a fire hazard now
and now it's an indian wedding
now here's the strat if you see me
outside the grenadine yes the better
that you can talk to me yeah yeah
exactly
but that's like that's like playing
gotcha yeah
sorry you mentioned because i don't
leave my room but maybe if you do we can
talk a little bit unless i'm in a rush
then i'll be like sorry
because then it's always that it's
always that instance of like if someone
recognizes you in those kinds of like
outside convention settings yeah all it
takes is for one person to be like oh my
god connor for everyone to just yeah
[ __ ] whip their heads around and then
a crowd gets full yeah yeah yeah
conventions when there's crowd people
normally want to see what the crowd's
about yeah yeah
so
yeah i remember the worst i saw it
before was you at the singaporean
convention where i it was it was like
traveling next to [ __ ] justin bieber
you know
like i we we had like this that was
pretty good we had like panels to go to
and i remember it was just like you
could not take two steps without being
stopped yeah and uh that was the first
time i had to get security yeah oh wow
and i was like did you get security yeah
i had to because the con was literally
like if you keep going you're gonna be a
fire hazard yeah yeah and so i was like
this is cool but also really [ __ ]
weird yeah uh fire hazard just because
you're like blocking walkways or
something it's not not like it's a big
deal but like if you if it's not like
someone's there with a [ __ ] match but
like people are stopping right so if you
if you just stop in a hallway or
something it's technically a fire hazard
yeah
a lot of the venues can be like punished
if that like gets yeah yeah around
that's happening you know 10 people stop
that's fine that's manageable 50 people
stop you know you're kind of
you're kind of you know getting in the
way of people if like 100 200 people
stop then you are stopping the flow of
people walking about you know
causing
literal i was going to call it human
traffic
like is there like a world you are human
you are human trafficking right now
like i don't know what the
word is or the term is but it's
basically human trafficking
yeah a human trafficking jab yes i went
to a convention i think you went to the
same one or an image in case i get
annoyed um that apparent one year they
had uh markiplier at the convention yeah
and apparently this is like the first
convention the markiplier ever did
yeah and uh i i they spoke about this
like it was like the zombie apocalypse
dude because apparently right what
happened was is that you know uh i think
some did
jacksepticeye go to
uh one of the years i think i remember
it was a really big big [ __ ] deal and
the convention like runners didn't like
they knew youtube and they knew that it
was like a big deal but they didn't
quite understand yeah like how big of a
deal it was so they were like woefully
unprepared yeah for like uh like
markiplier's audience
and apparently they were just like it
was like insane like the the security
barriers didn't like have anything
really yeah and so
like apparently it was like stampedes
like people were just getting like hurt
and they had like one security guy for
like a thousand people when only a
hundred people should have turned up and
they didn't plan you know and they had
because they had like they paid i don't
know god god knows a lot of money for
that one extra and that one marvel movie
and they were like well he's a big deal
yeah yeah
so it's kind of like they just kind of
didn't get it and they talked about
absolute nightmares yeah they talked
about it as if it was like a scene
ripped straight out of like like like
like
like
or something yeah like dead rising it's
just like yeah it was insane apparently
but like
every single time anything would come up
they'd be like the event that shall not
be named
such a disaster like trying to manage
this that they they the convention i
they think that their reasoning was that
they like banned uh him from coming back
and i said i was like something was your
problem though yeah definitely i don't
know i i can't remember exactly how dare
you be too popular yeah right our
convention i i think that that's
something like that they it was really
like they had [ __ ] up massively and
not considered well i think yeah you
know it's it's events like this that
have
thankfully made
events and people and not just events
but also like influencers themselves uh
no i know i know i hate the word i hate
but like we're like you know people like
us
we are not the same we don't like those
no no because like the reason i talk
about like you know youtubers or you
know you know tick tocks or whatever is
that we we came we came from like you
know we all came from the same place and
we don't want to
we don't want to feel like we you know
we don't need security we don't need to
worry about this we're like we're like
we're like the man of the people you
know but like at the same time there's
been enough incidents like the
markiplier thing like tanacon you know
like a lot there's been enough other
influencers who have set the president
to be like things can go really really
[ __ ] wrong if you don't plan [ __ ] out
because you we know that you want to be
seen as you know the casual person you
know you you know the same you know the
same as everyone else but you do have a
massive audience and you need to like
it's gotten to the point where a lot of
people need to think about how do they
manage the audience they have irl
because you see a number you see a
number on your youtube and you're just
like that's ten thousand people that's a
hundred thousand people it's it's just a
number but when you translate that
number even if it's just like a tenth of
the number you see on your youtube
channel to real
no l yeah i don't know what's going on
situation because like normally like
with how trash chase has grown over like
the past few years normally we'd like
we'd get to like ramp up the experience
be like okay guys i think we're reaching
that point where we need to kind of
start thinking about this kind of stuff
think about that but because it's just
been two years of us talking in japan
and we have no idea what it's going to
be like when we like i guess return to
the rest of the world and conventions
and stuff like that i'm
we're just playing a guessing game a lot
of the time and like what we're gonna
need and how we're gonna manage it last
time i went to ax i could like easily
walk through it all and there was like
maybe like i don't know 50 50 chance
that i would someone would recognize me
yeah and that's when i had like what 400
000 subs or something yeah yeah
so and that was before trashes obviously
yeah so that's i don't know what it's
gonna be like now i really who knows
yeah
yeah not excited for it i'm like i'm
excited i'm excited about dreading yeah
i'm like oh god i don't want to cause
any problems it's like it's like equal i
want to meet everyone i want to say hi
to you guys
excitement equal amounts terrifying yeah
yeah say you say me i'm i'm nervous in
both ways i'm like i'm excited to go
experience conventions and just go see
the vibe and everything again i'm scared
to see
how things have changed after uh after
last year's mourning the loss of my
weird convention stories probably now
you know i i don't get to stay in random
discord airbnb's that when i met people
online
yeah that's not gonna happen anymore
that sucks
that was fun fun fun stories weird
moments in my life he will reminisce as
he sits in his five-star hotel
i'm i'm just like you for real
he doesn't miss that conor connor's just
like give me the [ __ ] five-star hotel
right now
it's
fun but also it's like god damn i that
was that was no way to live
like damn did you live like this
i think i got all my really stupid ideas
out of my head and now i'm trying to be
more sensible and take care of myself
and yeah
it's time to adult now